guys he's now top 10 on the new york
times best sellers list with his new
book what's up melo how we doing
number seven number seven number seven
yeah yeah just a bit by the way you get
that in there you get that match the
jersey number ironic right oh man i love
it absolutely
congratulations with that by the way i
know you and gee um a couple weeks ago
talked about your book tour and when you
think about it here you are trying to
gear up
for your 19th season you're on a quest
to win a championship all the while
you're also an author how do you balance
it
it's it's actually it's easy you know
it's easy i mean once you
you know basketball comes first that's
that's a no-brainer you know everything
everything else after that is just
extracurricular activity so as long as
you're able to stay solid and lock in on
what you need to lock in on
you know
you have time and you have room to do
other things mellow big game's got a
smile on his face because i think he's
just happy you're finally here is that
what you're thinking over there
man
i'm very happy you know i was fortunate
enough a few years back when mitch
kupchak was gm
to sit in on on a little presentation
and you know things didn't work out the
way
they did but he's here now he's here now
and that's that's that's the only thing
that matters and i have a question
because
after 15 or 16 17 years
people try to write you off and people
try to say okay you're at the end of
your career
and then you pop up in portland i said
damn i knew it i knew i knew i knew he
wasn't done
talk about that man talk about how in
your mind you know because veteran
players have wisdom they might not be 22
anymore but talk about how that has
evolved from being the carmelo who was a
dynamic scorer to now being the you know
like the x factor now uh at this point
of your career
yeah well i mean we we all understand
the game right we are students of the
game so
you know if you do the history of the
game nobody never stayed the same right
there's going to always be
adjustments that you have to make you
always have to adapt to certain
situations and certain roles
uh because of you know a big part of
that is that narrative of as you get
older you you lose something and
for me i've always it never was a
basketball thing with me i always
believed in myself i always knew
and know what i could do on a basketball
court i always rely on
my my work ethic
you know being in the gym being
knowledgeable at a game uh oh you know
sharper than my my mental and in it i
think once i got to that point you know
basketball just became it it was it was
more easier for me it was it was more
efficient
for me because i i i put those ten
thousand hours in i put the twenty
thousand dollars in and you know
behind the doors behind the scenes at
night and in the morning and working out
when nobody is there like people people
don't know that they may hear it but
they don't they don't know that they
don't understand what that what that
takes
uh and for me to be taken away from the
game for that year and some change
that really gave me
it rejuvenated me it gave me a new a
newfound passion uh about the game from
a whole different perspective and i
think what i'm what you're experiencing
now and what you have experienced when i
was in portland is that passion
amen yeah well said well said um
spreading the floor in today's nba
especially with the roster around you is
key career best from three at 42 percent
how much work
mello and i'm glad you brought up that
that that word before efficiency how
much how much work do you put into that
part of your game because every single
year you've gotten more and more
efficient from there well you have to
listen the game is getting younger
you have to you have to still find two
you know fine tune those those skills
and then
you know you those those knives in the
drawer man you got to keep them sharp
for me i've always tried to figure out
how to
stay sharp and how to stay ahead of the
game how to stay ahead of my competition
how to be smarter how to utilize things
differently
like like you said earlier man it's i'm
not 22 no more so i got to go about
things a little bit differently i got to
think things through
uh more so now than i had to
when i was 22 when i could just go and
play off a pure skill talent and just
being green and just being raw so you
know the times have changed man but i'm
honestly i'm blessed man
i'm 19 years in this nba man yeah you
know this this is the nba 75th
birthday coming up so and for me to say
that i've almost spent 19 20 years of
that uh that's
i'm blessed man that's that's the only
thing i can say
melo you know when it comes to winning
which is obviously your goal
um
it takes a team and we've talked to the
big three already when it comes to
russell a.d and lebron and each have
echoed that sentiment here today and
when it comes to the relationship
between you and lebron the friendship we
know goes beyond basketball obviously
the battles over the years with the two
of you well documented always they've
always been fun to watch but you
recently just said at this point of your
career i'm curious that you needed to
hear directly from him why was that
important when it came to joining the
lakers
because i know
i know our friendship i know our our
brotherhood that we have i know the
connection that we have
and
over the years we've kind of been
dipping and dabbing that oh let's play
together let's do this and listen to
that but
it wasn't that and and at this point in
time where we both are in our careers i
think we both needed to hear that i
needed to hear
i need you i want you like let's
let's go i i really didn't need it i
needed to hear that that affirmation uh
whereas before it was just you know come
on i think this would be cool i think
it'd be dude let's make it happen
it was a different feeling it was a
different vibe at this point
i mean mellow so many
he's in the back he's in the background
right now dancing
i mean so many future hall of famers on
this team like what's the pecking order
what's the pending order like who gets
to eat first on the plane the vegas trip
who is
i'm the oldest man by a couple months so
yeah you know that that's that's the
pecking order right there but you know
it's it's a it's a level of respect that
we all have for each other and i think
that's that's that's the most important
thing you know we respect each other as
you know not just as basketball players
but as men and when you when you have
that you're able to communicate better
you're able to hold each other
accountable you know more because you
know let's be quite frank man there's
it's gonna be ups and downs this year we
ain't gonna have it all figured out at
every time i would love that
but you know this this is a long journey
and i just i just want to i want to go
through all the
the leaps and in and hoops and loops and
valleys and hills and mountains uh that
we're going to go to i want to
experience that because i know at the
end of the day if we do what we got to
do it's going to make that journey you
know that much better
great stuff from carmelo anthony man we
we appreciate you and
my you know from a guy that has an
italian mother 100 percent i loved your
italian meal reference that he had uh
i appreciate it doesn't matter who's
cooking in the kitchen and how old they
are as long as the food tastes great
that's all that great
yes sir
all right we appreciate you mello thanks
so much man thanks so much absolutely
thank you man thank you all right